alors bonjour à la planète vient
roulement de tambour 60 ans vous
entendez merci à toute l'équipe de
tintane canada qui évidemment avant les
joueurs changent au fil des saisons et
des émissions mais c'est des personnes
qui se portent volontaires comme un
arrivants qu'on retrouve jours à paris
il ya ici eu avec nous comme une
espionne
mais ce n'est pas une espionne une
invité mystère dont il faudra déterminer
l'identité dans quelques instants bon
jour un mystère bonjour à tous nous
avons marie claude sénécal qui est avec
nous parce que vous avez marie claude
simard du service web alors monsieur
alors tout le monde et de la section
espagnole de radio canada international
merci à tous d'être là aujourd'hui vous
connaissez comment ça fonctionne vous ne
savez pas plus que ce qu invité mystère
mais vous l'apprendre il ya des
questions à cette émission est la
première on commence tout de suite c'est
beau et c'est assez simple aujourd'hui
il suffit de déterminer le sujet de
l'émission je vous ai regardé une vidéo
et c'est au premier qui me dit qu'elle
est le sujet de l'émission pour emporter
sur quel et cross qui fonctionne cet
écran la tournée on regarde les images
et vous me dites les mots qui vous
viendra le premier qui a la réponse
gagne 10 points
le monde des talibans
des arts de la salle lumière ces dépôts
- oui qui rentrent dans la défense des
couleurs mais plus encore la belle à la
science et si les idées aux imaginations
imagination
ça en fait des most appris qu'ils
décrivent effectivement ce dont on va
perdre aujourd'hui regardez les niant
qu'ils créent en couleurs dans la poche
d'un homme d'affaires
et voici personne n'a la bonne réponse
aujourd'hui la créativité c'est bon non
mais attendez le monde des arts c'est le
monde de la créativité
oui bien sûr sans créativité pas d'art
oui qui se fait ici c'est la créativité
à preuve notre invité mystère qui
appartient à un autre secteur que celui
très très à l'aise nous compliquer la
vie
or personne n'a la bonne réponse pour la
première manche de notre jeu
questionnaire vous allez pouvoir vous
acheter voilà je vais quand même
attribué 20% aujourd'hui il veut un
point de vue qui est notre invité
mystère elle ne peut répondre que par
oui ou par non par un mois c'est une
dame
moi je connais son nom et j'ai aucune
idée de cesse tout ce que je connais de
lui quel est son nom commençons par ça
c'est nathalie nowak
comment leur poids dans cette veine de
novak novak novak w
comment je vais plus spécifiques
nathalie couillard novak même de couleur
rouge où il avait pris cmd france
d'accord pas trouvé la solution
oui mais ça ne m'aide pas du tout ok
allez quelque chose avec la créativité
la danse et scientifique
bingo bingo
alors félicitations 20 points juste
parce que en sourdine génie bagdad
on entend parler un peu au bureau d'à
côté mais oui j'essaye de faire
abstraction de tout ce que j'ai entendu
parler à tout le monde oui oui c'est bon
on change les règlements tous contre des
semaines alors madame novak novak me
cuias dites moi vous avez vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et pas seulement ici au
canada mais à travers le monde
multinationales aux multinationales aux
ide on a commencé à paris en fait il ya
13 ans et puis on a un bureau aussi à
barcelone et puis maintenant depuis
quatre ans à montréal
voilà et puis on a un réseau
international effectivement quellier est
relié à nos clients qui sont
principalement des européens et puis
aussi ma maintenant un petit peu plus de
québécois et comment s'appelle votre
entreprise il me fusio j'ai le droit de
le dire oui
faites jouer votre imagination voilà
qu'est ce que ça veut dire une fusion il
m
im riz m une fusion il fusio bon la
fusion de deux
oui il m'a joué sévrienne l'image
ouais pourquoi pas une nation fusion
super radar donnons jeux pan de ce qui
fait le cran aujourd'hui le cancre et
une fusion saison vous fait mieux fusion
une fille ou donc césar mais ça aurait
pu être l'infusion et et votre et des
couleurs vallier
bravo et très sérieusement les vous avez
dit un mot une feuille frasques les tout
est possible
comme l a dit ça veut dire ça vous avez
du tout les possibles tout à fait et ça
c'est votre langage de tous les jours
avec les chefs d'entreprise puis tout
est possible effectivement c'est pas
uniquement le monde des arts qui peut
être artiste l'activité artistique ou en
tous les cas créative elle se trouve
dans chacun de nous bien sûr maintenant
elle dépend aussi notre éducation de
notre milieu familial elle dépend aussi
de de l'environnement dans lequel on se
trouve
oui il dépend du patron disons-le et
elle dépend beaucoup du patron et des
autorisations à sourire des choses et
pour la petite histoire il me fusio ça
nous vient parce que mes associés et moi
même on a vécu trois ans au japon
et effectivement ça vient du t on qu'on
peut donner quelques points précieux
marie-claude fusion séance immerge dans
la culture d entreprise de nos clients
pour mieux les aider à diffuser et donc
on voulait vraiment s'appeler l'infusion
mai
bon bah il se trouve que on nous a
recommandé de faire un peu autrement et
le imsa peut être l'imagination ça peut
être l'intelligence managériale aussi
parce que où l'innovation managériale
parce que c'est ce qu'on fait aussi
alors il faut vous dire ils sont pas
seulement des gens qui donnent conseil
c'est des gens qui utilisent leur propre
conseil en entreprise
jeudi chefs d'entreprise mais au fond je
faisais une farce mauvaise farce
il ya trois chefs d'entreprise dans
votre entreprise on est trois
cofondateurs et après on fonctionne en
cercle donc en fonctionne par les
solidaires voilà mes potes des
porte-parole hexacore sous la forme de
concertation pourrait dire ou de la cra
si on en a parlé hier donc sous format
d'auto gouvernance en fait et donc
certains parmi nous donc on est 21
aujourd'hui dans les trois antennes dont
je vous ai pas d'accord et en fait
certains sont plus leaders que moi par
exemple sur tous ses finances alors que
je suis entrepreneur depuis 13 ans mais
c'est possible
et puis en fonction des thématiques
aussi contre est donc mais donc vous
avez trois bureaux vous avez dit oui
alors vous vous dirigez celui de
montréal tu as fait d'accord je copie
relate celui de montréal c'était sa
décision de partir de vinça pays
développés pour venir ici par allure
bella non au contraire
on a bien fait elle a bien fait mais
l'adaptation est disons vous vous rendez
compte que des limites à l'ouverture
d'une entreprise à ce qu'on vient de
jouer dans sa culture il ya des patrons
qui veulent vous rencontrer d'ici moi je
veux développer la créativité vis chez
mes employés je veux qu'ils soient plus
rapides plus intéressé plus impliqués et
des patrons ou des employés ben oui et
c'est bien souvent plus les employés que
les patrons mais dans quel genre
d'entreprise est ce que vous travaillez
lorsque radio canada c'est une boîte de
création de créativité on pourrait
travailler pour radio canada
en fait on s'intéresse à toute la
logique de d'optimisation d'une culture
de renforcement d'une culture
d'entreprise
donc on peut travailler sur la vision on
peut travailler sur les valeurs on peut
travailler sur un sujet très très
spécifique qu'est l'innovation par
exemple où on peut travailler sur la
planification stratégique donc il ya
plein il ya plein de sujets d'âge
avouent qu'ils ont été massacrés en
partie des quelque chose qu'on crée
exemple au québec on travaille beaucoup
pour l'institution dont on peut
présenter la vidéo d'une fusion on vous
a volé des images un problème être
surprise ça va être chouette des
collègues qui travaille toujours avec
vous et puis donc ya pas de sens mais on
voit les images c'est le site web ici au
québec qu'on peut voir on voit l'équipe
de montréal voilà trois personnes vous
êtes un peu seul et puis là vous avez
paris évidemment tard il centre de
l'univers où on va sûrement quelques
semaines quand on cumule je le dis on
l'annonçait la semaine dernière vincent
de paris et donc voit sa vie à l'autre
équipe qui est temps et puis ensuite on
ça c'est des images qu'on a tourné nous
ça nous a coûté très cher et ce temps
n'était vous piquer des images sur votre
sur youtube seront trouve tout et de
tous ces jours ci et j'ai hâte qu'on y
arrive aux images sur ie sur youtube ces
images plus vite voilà ça y est ça y est
c'est lancé c'est des gens vous
reconnaissez c'est à paris où marianne
st ça c'est à paris que je tapais vous
connaissez cette personne complice est
d'accord et coéquipière donc on peut
tous ces gens là ont la charge de
l'entreprise alors élise est parti faire
le tour du monde
cela oui ça c'est yael c'est un des
cofondateurs et tout le monde chez vous
a pas tout le monde mais beaucoup de
gens ont des intérêts tout à fait je
dirais divergent mais différent du souci
de l'entreprise et vous favorisez ça oui
alors après on a quand même hein
on va dire un socle commun qui est de
révéler le vivant dans les organisations
c'est ce qui nous relie donc de de faire
en sorte aussi que souvent on dit que la
gestion de changement que l'amélioration
l'optimisation dans les organisations
doit être par la souffrance et nous on
estime que non ça doit être par le fun
part par la collégialité aussi de bonne
engueulade et aussi par des méthodes qui
sont très très éprouvés maintenant mais
qui à l'époque ne l'était pas parce que
ça fait 13 ans quand on fait ça et voilà
donc le changement car la souffrance je
m'en souvenir
j'ai besoin moi de l'exerice pour
m'approcher notre retard c'est la salle
ok alors je veux quand même mon exemple
concret vous arrivez dans une entreprise
on vous demande quoi où vous leur dites
quoi alors on nous demande souvent on
peut rentrer par exemple en ce moment au
québec on ya beaucoup de défis sur
l'innovation
donc on veut que nos gestionnaires
deviennent de bons innovateur où de bons
créatif et générateur de valeur
là vous parliez tout à l'heure du
secteur ben création et secteur bancaire
explique quand même détrompez vous c'est
très très créatif le secteur bancaire ça
dépend où
d'ailleurs dans le secteur bancaire il
ya en ce moment la volonté d'essayer de
créer des communautés de pratique où il
n'y a pas forcément effectivement le
chef qui dit quoi faire mais il ya un
partage d'énergie ou d'initiatives et
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle le mot des
escouades il ya beaucoup d' équipe
notamment à montréal qui s'y mettent et
on appelle ça le mode agile et alors
c'est assez intéressant parce que je
trouve qu'ici il ya beaucoup de puristes
sur les méthodes
alors que nous chez une fusion
n'amalgame tout plein de méthode pour
être au plus proche du besoin du client
et puis justement de lui donner du sens
et de faire en sorte qui fait ça avec
plaisir donc dans notre petit schéma il
y avait confiance et plaisir c'est nos
deux valeurs limites et à chaque fois on
essaye de les introduire dans nos
accompagnement mais oui dans le secteur
bancaire il ya beaucoup d'entreprises
qui enfin il ya beaucoup d'institutions
qui nous a
elle au départ pour faire une
planification stratégique sur deux jours
puis on leur dit mais on peut pas en
deux jours donc
parce qu'en deux jours c'est c'est un
peu de la poudre aux yeux
donc est ce que vous nous permettez d'
élargir votre cercle et puis on va
essayer de créer les conditions pour
qu'ils deviennent les propres meneur de
jeu donc ce qu'on appelle les et
novateur où les agents de transformation
afin de changer les roues d'un
dictionnaire d'or est une entreprise
soit au monde par exemple comment on
peut partager les revenus de
l'entreprise c'est ce qu'ils font même
si les revenus sont moindres dans
certains cas d'un certain - s'il ya
moins d'argent parce que dans le monde
bancaire on a vu où sont allés les
revenus ça vient pas suffisamment 10
millions de dollars on a appris ça cette
semaine au niveau des salaires des six
grands dirigeants des banques
canadiennes salaire annuel voici notre
deuxième manche je traite les lumières
on est prêt pour l'été ça va bien
aujourd'hui ça déboule j'ai ma boule en
studio ça déboule alors les plâtres la
deuxième manche ça vaut pour 30%
l'examen final
voici la question combien coûte en ce
moment vous pouvez répondre veut
participer cette fois ci vous avez
importants comme tout le monde d'accord
alors voici deuxième manche de notre jeu
combien coûte en ce moment même ce
printemps tel qu'on peut le voir sur les
publicités vues par les internautes
canadiens sur facebook un billet aller
retour montréal paris 660 $ qui est le
plus proche de la bonne réponse 660
dollars ça dépend des saisons mais si
c'est en ce moment c'est 550 dollars
cette centrale est les spécialistes 1
jeudi
elle prend l'avion souvent
passer d'un avion lui alors qu'il ya 10
730 bien sûr n'est pas classé 720
dollars actuellement
l'aveyron compte mars au mois de mars
attendez mais vous l'avez magazine et
quand c'est la semaine de relâche
c'était plus élevé je me suis fait avoir
jv la semaine prochaine non j'y vais
tout de suite nous y allons tout de
suite par la voie des lames rdr dont la
magie de skype
nous allons rejoint concorde un nom de
fête alors il ya deux personnes qui nous
attendent
à paris on voit pas beaucoup les
feuilles c'est pas tellement vert chez
vous en ce moment bonjour est ce que
vous nous entendez bien on a l'image
skype sont la leçon aux téléphones bon
jour il ya beaucoup de feuilles de
bonjour est-ce que vous reconnaissez une
de ces deux personnes anne-marie celles
qui se trouvent à la gauche de l'écran 1
gauche attendaient sait où la gauche la
gauche à quoi on va faire jouer la vidéo
numéro 4 regardez bien la vidéo numéro 4
on se reporte dans notre machine à
remonter le temps
c'était il ya pour c'est ça c'est simple
je me bat mais regardez la place on
regarde à la voie la meilleure qualité
d'image ce jour là ouais on est ce qu'on
a le son il n'y a pas de sens à ça c'est
la première fois qu'on allait finalement
j'ai pas laissé une marque indélébile
parce que l'image n'était pas clair
vraiment là on va on retourne à paris
bonjour alors il s'agit et vous nous
aviez dit qu'elle vous nous aviez dit
que vous iriez à paris n'est ce pas
ouais alors oui steinbourg qui est avec
nous et les présidente et fondatrice du
club de lecture à faire il n'y a pas
trois présidentes chez oui en a qu'une
il ya une biais de la place pour du
progrès et puis vous êtes accompagné
d'une autre invité manon qui est une
québécoise à paris ça fera un beau titre
de romance et manon qui êtes vous
exactement qu'est ce que vous qu'est ce
que vous venez faire à l'émission
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose reliés à
la créativité ouzou si oui qui
perpétuent à paris pour présenter mon
livre à un livre parfait en ce moment et
est pour moi bien la date vient d'être
acté a su s'effacer au quotidien c'est
dans le processus et non pas la refaire
de performance alors je n'ai jamais été
là aujourd'hui avec vous qu'il ya une
bouffée d'art à paris ben justement ce
moment on voit la page couverture de
créer le meilleur de soi ce n'est pas la
première année que vous intéresser la
créativité on a été sur youtube on a des
preuves
vous voici ces images de l'automne
dernier remarque est bien mais il y
avoue une série de vidéos que vous avez
mis en ligne et pour certaines d'entre
elles il faut payer
vous donnez des cours de créativité oui
en fait des gens sur la planète
enfin un qui s'appelle revenir vers quoi
je tellement ça c'est reprendre contact
avec toi comme est de reconnaître par le
processus de création en mode insultent
et des marques
écoutez micheline vous avez 12 est en
belle compagnie c'était quelque chose
que vous planifiez depuis un bon bout
bon moment vous êtes à paris pour quelle
raison il ya un grand événement je crois
moi je suis de lecture
g j'ai un événement que je vais produire
la seule personne à la maison des
étudiants canadiens qui va avec une
célébration des d'auteur en une
quinzaine d'auteurs de français un
canadien qui vont être là plutôt d'un
invité alors tombé touahri on a bien
fait alors ouais vous êtes à paris aussi
parce qu'il ya le salon du livre de
paris on voit des images vous êtes vous
y
c'est une grosse grosse chose pour vous
une grosse affaire d'être une québécoise
à paris oui mais bon fallait qu'on
exposantes mais je suis là pour aller
faire quelques qu'est peu à la la à
l'avant on donnait dans l'édition
d'auteur et évidemment il ya aussi
beaucoup de contenu pour les
professionnels donc je me permets de
penser le petit chapeau des beaucoup
d'informations sur les huit criques on
peut aller chercher qui est vraiment
vraiment intéressante l2 mais il va y
avoir une conférence sur les débiteurs
dont l'afrique subsaharienne
alors on va aller voir qu'il faut pas
plus pour voir qu'il commence à voir
comment ça fonctionne là bas lorsque
vous avez vu nous voir la première fois
ici à l'émission il ya trois mois
longtemps vous aviez nous avez parlé de
votre coup de coeur pour la créativité
vous avez découvert plus tard dans la
vie
les clés de la créativité vous avez vous
êtes une personne créative mais là vous
avez mis le doigt sur des sons une pas
des recettes mais des clés qui ouvrent
les boîtes de récréative la découverte
de ces talents nos talents naturels et
effectivement ça fait un effet chaque
sur moi parce que sam avec défini d'une
fonction d'une façon que je que je
trouvais tellement avancé tellement
proches de qui j'étais mais c'est en
fait ce n'était pas des des talents que
je me je me donnais alors je me les
approprier et j'en suis ravi c'était un
bel exercice et tonique s'appelle le
talent et qui par carol doucet et
marseille de charles et oui il faut mais
aussi de la créativité de ces copies du
livre de manon et la juge
j'ai commencé à deux ça vaille est juste
avant de partir c'est un magnifique
livre
il est beau il est généreux idée il est
vraiment et nous encourage vraiment à
aller faire des petits l'exercice sur le
plan de la créativité par le bien de ses
mains par le biais de la peinture et
d'autres techniques et tout petit truc
besoin de donner le cube de m'annoncer
que tout contrôlé par la wii
premièrement le lac la biche et est
reliée à l'introspection
mais aussi elle est d'abord une démarche
beaucoup plus fluide entre le lac et
rationnelle et l'est l institution parce
que le but dans la vie ce n'est pas
juste d'être en mode un super parce que
le tout s'écroule on perd nos points de
repères mais c'est tellement intéressant
d'aller accéder à cet âge est stocké à
l'intérieur alors de perdre nos points
de repères par la création pour mieux te
connaître tous se reconnaître et
extrêmement qui de pouvoir créer une
gamme d'abord géant dans est avant tout
c'est là où on accède à la note
créativité la portion peut pas devenir
plus créatives un peu tout d'abord un
cours à plus vaste pour avoir accès à
notre atypique et déjà la fiche contient
nathalie peut le confirmer que dans les
entreprises quand on est bien car on est
on est moins stressé quand on sent en
confiance justement on a accès à le
calme nous permet d'ouvrir les vannes
littéralement vidés quand même des
petits trucs dont l une des premières
choses que tu nous suggère des deux
équipes pédagogiques des petits
matériels de ta nature parce que oui on
va faire de la peinture et des plus
constate tout au long du livre quand les
sables oubliés pour aller puiser dans
cette sauce la con à l'intérieur de ce
même 4 enfin je voulais vous parler de
peinture d'art ce serait bien le temps
qu'on en parle on parle juste du monde
des affaires depuis que l'émission a
commencé bien sûr alors sérieusement on
a quelque chose que notre invité ici
nathalie nous a envoyé nous a prévenus
que ça allait on en parle et je sais pas
si les autres sont au courant mais en
tout cas ça fait un beau sujet de
conversation ça s'appelle la
clairvoyance de
rené magritte un peintre français on va
regarder l'image c'est magnifique ce qui
fait je vais je vais voir cette oeuvre
d'accord ça a quelque chose à voir avec
la créativité
non j'ai rien compris l'image donc j'ai
dit on va faire une vidéo j'ai demandé
aux services spécialisés de tweb de
crise vidéo ça c'est mon petit côté un
autoportrait en 1936 et savez moi je mon
sujet pas j'ai pas je perds en noir et
blanc
j'ai renversé l'image ça c'est ma
créativité là je lui fait sauter deux le
cerveau alors pourquoi on regarde ça il
ya un pigeon tient neuf et est le
peintre
déjà je me demandais ce cas quelles
sortes d'oiseaux dans consentants c'est
un pigeon de paris c'est ça pourrait
être un marchand de du québec beaucoup
d'imagination
mais ce qui est étonnant la danse et le
titre dans la clairvoyance on a besoin
d'eux parce que c'est aussi de se dire
qu'un objet
est perçu par une personne on le nomme à
priori dans le sens commun mais après on
perçoit tellement d'autres choses
derrière et c'est un peu ça qu'on fait
avec avec manon c'est d'essayer de
trouver des moyens de se dire que on a
plein de perception différente on a
plein de lunettes différentes églises
qu'on pourrait comment on peut
s'entraider pour verbaliser et faire en
sorte qu'on a un langage commun pour ma
part c'est dans les organisations mais
mais c'est dans une famille c'est pareil
c'est de se dire c'est essayer de se
dire qu'est ce qu'on met derrière ces
objets là et puis surtout ce que je
trouve assez génial là dedans c'est que
il voit tellement loin il voit ce qui
est à l'intérieur de l'oeuf mais réalisé
par will voilà et on a tellement besoin
de voir loin si moi j'ai peur je pense
que peut-être un internaute ou deux qui
comprend alors qu'il garde son flegme un
noise au de prime abord est tellement
une vue d'ensemble large parce qu'étant
où il voit très bien mais peut-être plus
en mesure de les glucides
est-ce qu'on a notre image toujours avec
paris et notre sauviat bell canada
oui c'est un mariage des technologies
aujourd'hui c'est fantastique un jeu ça
montre notre créativité
et puis avez vous profité un peu de
paris où vous êtes parler seulement
d'affaires j'ai pas le temps d'aller
goûter à la vie à mais faut essayer de
prendre le temps à travers tous les
favoris tous les petits moments et c'est
en quoi je crois et la magie des petits
passent donc à travers tout ce qu'on a à
faire de revenir dans le moment présent
qui donne en profitez donc de prendre
des belles marges en est à côté des
jardins du tambour est de toute beauté
elle les aide l écart est qu'il est bâti
seulement parce que je m'appelle je suis
fils axel très simple c'est de la neige
a fondu
on a une belle image de paris sous la
neige sous la dent
moi on va vous laisser filer d'accord
parce que le sata nous lâcher on
pourrait toujours demander combien a
coûté le billet d'avion pour celui qu'on
guérit bonnes questions
allez-y combien a coûté votre billet
d'avion aller retour autour de 160 g km
et stéphane 30% voilà trois points 668
détrôné alors bien ses chats oui alors
c'était manon la voix à la droite de m
comme muse pouvez aller voir sur le web
m comme muse vous allez retrouver
plusieurs références et aussi notre
championne de la lecture club de lecture
à faire ici à man mais jeudi mme bourque
voilà les missions pas tout à fait
terminé ce que je retiens de ce qu'elle
a dit c'est créer le calme j'ai passé ma
fin de semaine à y réfléchir et à voir
comment je peux faire ça de créer le cam
avant de créer justement pouvoir
ils disent que c'est ça en fait il faut
être un calme pour pouvoir créer au
pouvoir déçoivent gaillard puis faire
les procès civils et processus créatif
beaucoup plus riches
oui bon jusque vous prenez la parole
auquel vous mettre au défi va présenter
notre dernière vidéo aujourd'hui qui est
notre question tam tam et puis on va
vous demander de nous dévoiler à tous
qu'il est notre question cette semaine
qu'on ne pose à nos auditeurs nogent sur
aube tel est le facebook
obeidi morale paris printemps hiver
soyez créatifs et utiliser ces quatre
mots pour les clairons phrase qui
c'était les débuts d'ee votre jeu
premier grand roman c'est ça ouais
non on s'est dit on va enfin lancer un
défi créatif
pourquoi par quelle bonne idée a
personne qui va réponse est non il ya eu
plusieurs et pas oui j'étais surpris son
prix voir autant transformer en poète et
wii puis j'avoue de de distribuer ici
pas à tous vous pouvez lire avec quoi le
voisin si le non se souvenant qu'il faut
parler devant le micro c'est bon je sais
pas moi j'ai plus de copies alors ça va
être atteint mais bon voilà donc une
copie pour 4 ça va alors il ya une
réponse j'ai sélectionné les meilleurs
au québec qui appelle qui écrit de
poitiers en france elle s'appelle anne
pellois anne pélouas et puis
marie-claude vous avez l'honneur de lire
la première réponse en scène excusez moi
je recommence en ce petit matin de
printemps fleuri à paris je filais le
coeur léger en taxi 20 l'aéroport
songeant à cet hiver encore mais je qui
m'attendent raid en quelques heures à
peine
à montréal c'est joli donc nous on vous
aide à écrire votre première pensée est
commencé devant une feuille blanche on
ne s'aime pas
on a dit non on va leur donner quatre
mots ils vont partir avec ça ils vont
faire un chef-d'oeuvre et je passais
voici une des plus belle réponse est
envoyé par monsieur ou madame je pensais
madame anita mettra ya je ne sais pas où
elle habite
mais voici ce qu'elle dit et puis on va
demander à nathalie donner la réponse
en arrivant à paris au printemps je
laissais en même temps derrière montréal
et son hiver c'est très beau
me semble la partie délaissée l'hiver
une personne qui nous écrit du québec
anne claudie vierge contre coeur en fête
à vient de contrecoeur mais trait
d'union moi ça me fait un bond à qui
veut donner la réponse qui veut
[Musique]
paris sous la neige au printemps il n'y
a pas de doute je me croirais à montréal
quand les arbres tarder à se parer de
bourgeons ou vert tendre que le soleil
bien qu'ils étaient bien qu'étant cela
peine à nous chauffer le visage et puis
on à françoise depardieu qui nous est
alors elle a une explication avant de
donner sa phrase c'est assez long son
histoire mais c'est alors vous ici
commence en disant d'ailleurs à l'eau
les amis du canada donc je me suis
souvent trouvé devant une page blanche
du temps des dissertations au lycée et
je me souviendrai toujours de mes mains
moites s'agrippant à cette page certains
soirs alors qu'il ne me restait plus
qu'une heure pour terminer ma dit certes
votre proposition de 4 mo pour briser la
glace est amusante
alors voici comment elles commenceraient
mon premier grand roman
écoutez guerre j'ouvre les guillemets
vous avez besoin de grandes respirations
je pense ce qui est des points
non je me lance avec son visage blanc
comme la neige qui tombait sur montréal
ce jour là la boulangère des noix son
tablier et laissant derrière elles aussi
vite qu'elle le puce et nougats coller
aux étagères et son mari planté dans la
poussière d'un interminable ennui elle
se rendit d'un pas pressé à l'aérodrome
le plus proche pour y acheter un billet
simple et sans retour pour paris et son
printemps farci de tous ces plaisirs
aphrodisiaques
les petits comme les gros et il ne
s'agissait que de la première phrase
mais la wii a la demo real bord la
première
montréal
avec cela
comme la neige oui c'est derrière les
envies domaine d'accord mais j'aimais
bien moi j'aimais bien ça france
pensez vous qu'elle devrait aller je
dirais certainement le roman de madame
de paris mais la france donc je me
rappelle qu' proust non par lui
non mais tu avais pas d s'ils m'offrent
et des motets de descriptions n'en plus
finir
si on attend que ça marchait très fort
les slovènes en les rendant beaucoup
beaucoup de descriptions voilà c'est
terminé
sauf qu'il reste les lumières avec la
grosse boule qui est oui au jeu de la
grosse boule voilà alors c'est
intéressant car on a parlé durant toute
l'émission je pense pas qu'on ait des
réponses
voici au sujet de la créativité
quelle est l'origine de ce mot
créativité est ce que c'est une origine
cac canadienne française ou autre
rae a créé caisse et espagnols espagnols
non non c'est palatin donc mais qui se
maintient non non non c'est vrai que moi
j'ai des regrets pour donc pour autres
l'étymologie en grec une étymologie en
latin c'est un peu normal bien me donner
50 points mais je pense que ce que vous
pouvez me dire autre chose que les grecs
arabe non ce choix c'est français hockey
canadien choix la lettre autre bon 50.50
points 50 points vous avez tous les
poids aujourd'hui vous avez 100% c'est
qu'on passe à autre les états unis
d'amérique
oui créativité ce mot est apparue donc
c'est un calque de l'américain
néologisme des années 40
sans aucune connotation artistique non
non ça va oui en fait oui parce que moi
je je je tique toujours sur le mot
créativité alors que je parle toujours
de l'élan créateur ou de la création
effectivement maintenant je comprends
que ce soit un néologisme
et oui mais parce que c'est un
néologisme anna le mot création
effectivement c'est ce que j'allais dire
c'est fantastique à la bcc est adapté en
français pour la première fois en 1970
dans le grand dictionnaire robert en
1968 l'académie française s'est traîné
de la patte pendant encore une année
1971 il est d'accord on va être créatif
on va ajouter ça et puis mais ça vient
ça voulait simplement désigné au départ
la capacité de créer des idées grâce à
l'imagination de comptable j'ai ajouté
le comptable mais pourquoi vous croyez
tout ce qu on dit merci beaucoup
à sanaa ils vont venir nathalie nowak
merci beaucoup merci
une fusion souvenez-vous sa physio
plusieurs révisions
comment on appelle im f us et on va
avoir besoin de bientôt j'ai
l'impression dans le monde entier
et puis marie claude simard et nous la
semaine prochaine j'ai aucune idée les
comparses iv des suggestions allez-y on
pourrait parler de violences policières
ce serait un peu
plus tapageur et plus débat ils seront
au printemps
allez vous êtes là la semaine prochaine
inch'allah
marisa obligé d'être là elle fait ça
c'est ça votre bien chaque semaine elle
travaille pour une autre section de
radio canada
oui une ancienne collègue de travail
toujours reconnaissant de votre passage
ici l émission fait toujours plaisir de
venir d'ailleurs on salue la planète une
dernière fois
pendant que c'est encore possible
et nous la semaine prochaine j'ai aucune
idée des comparses il fait des
suggestions allez-y on pourrait parler
de violences policières mais ce serait
un peu tapageur et puis je sais pas ils
seront printemps j'avais vous êtes là la
semaine prochaine inch'allah
elle m'a richard obligé d'être là elle
fait ça c'est ça votre bea
chaque semaine elle travaille pour une
autre section de radio canada wind
ancien collègue de travail toujours
reconnaissant de votre passage ici à
l'émission fait toujours plaisir de
venir